we had this fellow uh and he uh
made a video 45 minute video uh
criticizing my notion of science
okay and i think it came in very handy
partly because i was doing the videos
okay i was uh in the process of doing
some of these videos talking about
science he criticized like six or seven
of them i don't remember how many i've
got up there
and um
and so he criticized them and i'm gonna
analyze point by point that he made i
think it's good that he did it
in great measure because 99 of the
people out there believe just like he
does they have the same they went to the
same monastery and they learned the same
i call it the mathematical method they
caught the scientific methods got
nothing to do with science okay and
today we're gonna show that
we're gonna show that his method fails
completely okay hopefully we can uh find
out you know whether he's even in the
ballpark
okay so uh this is what this fellow said
with respect to what i'm gonna talk
about today again i'm going to be
analyzing point by point today
we're going to look at a couple points
and these are the points okay
here let me give me a second here let me
prepare it okay
and here it goes listen tight there we
go
questions and issues addressed in this
rebuttal include this fellow claims that
discovering the nature of gravity is
very difficult and that the
mathematicians don't have all the
answers
then he contradicts himself by asserting
that the mathematicians have already
figured out the mechanism of gravity
specifically the answer to why the moon
doesn't fly out of the solar system
so
which is true
because it's not exactly easy you don't
just drop something go
oh that fell i guess it's invisible
green pixies then
so
why haven't the mathematicians who call
themselves physicists figured out the
extremely simple mechanism of gravity
after 2 500 years of research
experiments and math
this fellow replies
that the mathematicians don't yet have
all the answers
that might be because we don't have all
the answers yet
science can answer those questions it
just may not be fully complete yet
but then in the same breath he boasts
that the mathematicians do indeed know
the cause of gravity that all you are
required to do from now on is memorize
and repeat what they have already
discovered
well that's because earth being space
time
and bent space time can alter the 3d
trajectory of an object so that question
has been answered
maybe try taking a science course
okay
so uh he says he doesn't know what
gravity is he drops something for
example in this case a spoon
he doesn't know
uh why that falls
says no mathematician mathematician i'm
sorry on earth can tell you that
they all have all these equations they
did all the experiments ever
thought about no one can explain why
this spoon falls to the earth we have
two objects the earth and the spoon not
a single mathematician not a single
idiot at any university on the planet
can tell you why
what causes
this spoon to fall to the floor
okay that's the issue
okay so here we go
here's a here's what this fellow
believes he believes that the moon rolls
around space time warp time he says that
there's something called time
a physical object that is bent okay
that's what he says okay here it is this
is what he believes in this is what he
was taught in hi in high school or at
the monastery you know this is where the
altar boys get you know their
information of how i mean this
ridiculous thing is what these people
believe in and 99 of the people out
there believe in this garbage this
nonsense this poppycock okay this is
what they say science is
okay so here we have um you know uh the
the notion that they have out there
again a different version of it uh
warp space time is that what they call
it what time bent time as he says
okay so so we have bent time great and
this is nasa this is the official
version okay there you see it and you
can see the caption there gravity pro be
measured how gravity warps space and
time
okay so everybody says the same thing
and they illustrate it i mean there
should be no no reason not to doubt this
nonsense coming out of nasa because all
these phds in mathematics right they
tell you in your face that it's warped
space and time and you're staring at it
now i don't know what part you would not
understand when you're staring at what
they're saying they're saying that time
is warped that time is bent okay
and uh and then when you question them
then they put this cartoon to ridicule
you they say understanding gravity space
time is like this rubber sheet massive
objects distort the sheet and
and a student says they distort it
because they're pulled down by what and
the other fella immediately changes the
subject says space time is like the set
of equations for which any analogy must
be an approximation
well we have a little bit of problem
because this is not this is what they
illustrated and we need to explain why
the earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system okay and these people are telling
you that
the reason is that
the earth which is a three-dimensional
solid you know quite solid you know you
can
sit on it you jump on it right and
they're saying that that big object
called
uh earth or any planet even a moon why
it doesn't leave the solar system is
because time is bent
now what sense does that make and you
might say bill that's not what he said
let's hear it again let's make sure we
all understand what this individual said
and what everybody out there believes
let's put it one more time just for your
amusement okay here it goes okay give me
a second
well that's because earth bends time
and bent time can alter the 3d
trajectory of an object
been
time
can alter the 3d trajectory of an object
being
time
can alter the 3d
digitry of an object
did you hear it correctly or did i lie
the guy said bent time and that's what
prevents the earth from flying out of
the solar system this is the nonsense
that these altar boys learn at the
cambridge monastery or at nasa or
cern or who knows where
this is the nonsense that is out there
it's ridiculous nonsense that has
nothing to do with science or physics
okay so he says he doesn't understand
or no mathematician no mathematician on
earth can tell you why the spoon falls
to the floor
okay
and let's look at this let's look at
this simple
simple very simple issue that no one has
been able to solve in 10 000 years why a
spoon falls to the floor i mean how
difficult can that be we've got a spoon
and we have the earth
you don't like that you like an
astronaut and the earth
you don't like that you like the moon
and the earth
two objects no matter how you look at it
two objects okay here we have the spoon
and the earth no one on earth can tell
you why that spoon falls to the earth
let's look at it okay here we go this is
the spoon falling down to earth
and so you say well why does a spoon
fall to earth i mean why does it fall
upwards towards the sky towards the
ceiling why does it fall to the floor
okay
important question
okay so this fella says well i can do it
with pixies green pixies
so i didn't know what a pixie was
exactly i mean i had an idea but i
looked it up and these are the two
notions that are out there one of the
green pixies are these peter pan-like uh
gnomes or whatever they're flying around
okay we can do it with that and we have
the other green pixies where it's just
particles okay so we have these two
notions i'm going to go with
the one on the right and you can replace
each one of those dots with the green
pixies on the left no problem whatsoever
okay so here uh i want to know the
mechanism of grantham green pixies i'll
let him i'll let him simulate gravity
with his green pixies he can choose any
green pixies he wants okay here we go
are the green pixies pushing
the spoon downwards is that how gravity
works is this what he's going to explain
or is it that maybe they're pulling from
below somehow okay like here
is that's what's happening
which one is true well and i mean he's
got maybe a different explanation i can
only simulate uh you know with his green
pixies uh how i think that he might be
trying to simulate gravity but you know
i don't mind he can he can come up with
a different scenario and tell me no it's
neither push nor pull you know okay
you tell me
i don't know how you do with your green
pixies and i'm granting the green pixies
okay now if green pixies mean something
else that i don't know about and you
have a different mechanism then i'll
swallow my beer
okay
okay so here we have again the spoon in
free fall okay this is what we see
and and you say well bill how do you do
it you're so smart right okay smarty pan
let's see how you do it okay this is how
we do it we say that every atom of that
spoon is bound physically bound by
electromagnetic ropes very thin thinner
than uh the planck constant or thinner
than anything you can imagine we're
talking about every atom of that spoon
being connected to every atom of the
earth
and here we see the mechanism
this is why a spoon falls to the ground
because every atom of that spoon is
bound to every atom on earth and no i
did not draw every rope okay it's just
conceptual so that you can understand
the mechanism if the spoon is made of
gazillions of atoms and each one of
those is connected to the gazillion
gazillion gazillion atoms of the earth
you can see why as it falls the ropes
fan out
that's the mechanism mechanism of
gravity that none of these idiots from
cambridge from harvard from oxford and
from caltech none of these idiots these
mathematicians ever figured out it was
so simple all you had to do was make the
invisible objects that connect every
atom to the earth visible once you make
it visible the mechanism is kid stuff
it's for babies
okay
so let's make sure we understand why all
these mathematicians were never doing
science because to do science in in the
context of physics right you have to
make the invisible objects that mother
nature uses visible if you don't make
them visible you're doing magic
okay that's what it is these people
instead put concepts in there they said
we're going to do it with mass we're
going to do it with field we're going to
do it with energy
what is that there's not can you draw a
picture of energy please illustrate it
for me show me what energy is and then
you can talk okay but here we have uh
and you say bill where did you get this
nonsense of the ropes you know my rope
where did you get this nonsense that all
atoms are interconnected and that there
are invisible intangible ropes
well the first thing you have to
understand is that
um an object is not that which you can
see or touch
which is the definition everybody has
out there
existence exists is not that which you
can see or touch which is the definition
of exists that most people have out
there
and that's the one the mathematicians
cambridge and harvard that's the one
they use they use the see touch and so
they say let's go to the lab
what are you going to go for to the lab
for well i want to i want to find out
what gravity is how are you going to
find out in the lab with an experiment
you derange [ __ ] how are you going to
find out going to the lab when you can't
see or touch that which is invisible and
intangible
what part don't you understand
mother nature has invisible intangible
objects
there because the word object is not
defined as that which you can see or
touch the word object is defined as that
which has shape
this has shape a rope the
electromagnetic rope you cannot see or
touch so please don't go to the lab
don't waste your time don't waste your
brain your tiny brain
if you go to the lab you're never going
to figure out you have to sit back
visualize how mother nature could be
doing gravity and you say where did you
get this grove this that all atoms are
interconnected
okay so let's for those who require
proof and evidence because they think
science is about proof and evidence
and testing the hypothesis whatever that
nonsense is okay let's test the
hypothesis okay let's let's present
proof and evidence for all the those
deranged
individuals who went to college and and
just uh parroted the party line okay
here's uh a professor
phd in physics mathematics okay he's
gonna tell you where i got that from
here it is okay his name is uh richard
muller he's from berkeley university
listen carefully okay instead of opening
your mouth okay here it goes give me a
second here it goes
what's the force of gravity on me
it's the pull of the earth
on my body
so for example if you have the earth
with its big mass here and you have you
with your little mass here
that every atom on the earth
is pulling on every atom of you
you're also pulling on it
on the other hand a lot of atoms here
you're pulling on you're pulling on all
of them amazing thing about gravity is
it goes right through things
okay
you're pulling on every atom of the
earth
do that with space-time
how are you going to do with space-time
with warp time how are you going to pull
on an atom you know on earth
every atom in your body is pulling on
every atom on earth every atom on earth
is pulling on you how do you pull if not
with an elongated object
if every atom on earth is bound to every
atom in your body then you can see why
when you jump you fall back because now
you have a physical mechanism but to say
that you did it because of gravity or
which is what you're trying to explain
really or that you did it because mass
or or because of you know energy or
force or field what are you saying
what's the mechanism so i i consider
your stupid field your stupid energy
how do you explain the mechanism
i want to see i want to see the
mechanism that you propose for why why
this spoon falls to the floor
that's the issue if you cannot explain
it you're not a physicist you're a damn
mathematician that's all you are who's
opposing
using the word physics to label yourself
we don't have physicists on earth on any
university on the planet
this is the only site that does physic
we do it with objects we explain gravity
with objects we explain magnetism with
objects we explain electricity with
objects and obviously the working of the
atom okay so here it is one more uh time
okay just so you can see it so for
examples here
you have the earth there's a big mass
here and you have you with your little
mass here every atom on earth is pulling
on every atom of you
you're also pulling on it
are you listening or is it going through
your from one ear to the other with
nothing in between
the amazing thing about gravity is that
it goes right through things
how does gravity go right through things
unless every atom is connected to all
other atoms physically
that's the only way you can explain this
and the reason no one can explain why
two objects a spoon and the earth
you know in ten thousand years no one
has been able to explain gravity is
because they don't use objects they
don't use things
and if you're going to explain a
mechanism you need things you need to
make the invisible things that are here
which are untouchable and unseeable you
have to make those things visible then
someone can explain the mechanism
imagine if you're pulling on a rope
that's wound around a pulley and holding
a box
okay so you pull on the rope and the box
goes up
now let's get rid of the rope let's make
it an invisible rope
so the guy goes like this
and the box goes up
and you don't see the mechanism you say
how did the box go up every time he goes
like this the box goes up
and such a simple thing all you have to
do is make the rope visible and then
it's kid's stuff but as long as you
don't see the rope and you can't touch
the rope
people say oh it's magic
okay and that's the only difference the
only difference between what the
mathematicians do and what we do here is
that we make the objects visible that
mother nature uses father universe
whoever you believe in